نعم ولكن قالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
انها نجحت في تدريب جنود اوكرانيين على
استخدام تشالنجر تو في شهر واحد فقط فيما
يؤكد الخبراء الاوروبيون ايضا ان هذا غير
ممكن في اقل من ثلاثه اشهر على الاقل كيف
تصف هذا او تفسر هذا
كلاهما على حق فكلما تعلق الامر بتحليل
اداء القوات الاوكرانيه فانه يتعين تعليق
العمل بالمنطق المتعارف عليه فمن توقع في
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير العام الماضي
عندما اقتحمت القوات الروسيه العاصمه كييف
ان يتم طردها وبسرعه من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه ثم اثر ذلك تحقيق مكاسب عبر
ارجاء بلادهم ما قالته وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه
وجنرالاتها منطقي من حيث الحاجه الى
امتلاك الخبرات لكن الجنود الاوكرانيين
يبداون التدريب وهم لهم معرفه به بنوع
السلاح وكيفيه استخدامه يعرفون كيف
يستخدمون دبابه او صاروخا وذلك ما يجعل من
مده التعلم اكثر ايضا هناك الطاقه التي
يمنحها دافع الرغبه في التعلم ولذلك كان
تلقي المعلومات اسهل الظروف حكمت على
الاوكرانيين بسرعه مثل ما كان الامر يتعلق
باي تلميذ مجتهد في المدرسه واي تكنولوجيا
يتم تقديمها لهم سيجلبون اليها شغفهم
ومعارفهم السابقه سواء كانت من بريطانيا
والمانيا او فرنسا او الولايات المتحده او
بولندا
ويفاجئونهم بقدرتهم على سرعه امتلاك
القدرات سواء من حيث الحفاظ على العداد او
المفاجاه في كيفيه استخدام